getting all of our young people online
is essential
while schools are closed sadly though
not everyone is available
is able to afford the right technology
but one man is
fixing old laptops so that kids can use
them and then as you're about to see he
is delivering them
in his tuk talk that man is premgiani
and he joins us on
the program i should also mention prem
that it's not just you that we have to
introduce we have to introduce the
the tuk-tuk who goes by the name of tara
i'm informed
absolutely neil that's uh that's tara
and she's uh
she's helping me a very great deal at
the moment so tell us then prem how did
you come up with the idea
you're taking laptops and you're
converting them and then delivering them
yeah so um you know the lockdown was
announced on the sixth
i guess on the seventh i heard i'm a
governor of a local school
in the soap academy and um i i heard
from parents that they were
wondering how to cope with now having to
have multiple laptops
and um because i had like 32 years of
geek experience
in technology i um found that google had
a bit of software that would allow you
to take any old laptop really
less than about 10 years old and convert
them into a chromebook which is what all
the primary school kids need so
i did that i i i tested it it worked
fine
i posted on the local village and said
can i have some please
and i was stunned you know that the next
day there were six
sitting outside my door um i then went
out to another app called next door and
posted out there
uh by the 11th i had 11 of these and
another 11
and i i delivered five to local children
last friday
another 37 came in and um
i delivered 16 kids and then on monday
another 12.
so it was brilliant fantastic brilliant
is exactly
brilliant is exactly the word to
describe it i'm just i'm just wondering
what the
what the reaction has been um from from
the parents and
indeed from the children we've just been
looking actually at a lot of pictures of
you
with the kids themselves you're smiling
more than they are for goodness sake
probably because you've just enabled
them
to have to do their homework yes neil i
mean it is such a pleasure
and i'm sorry kids about the homework
but it is just such a pleasure i mean
you know
i just love smiles which is why i'm in
the business i'm in and
and uh and having those little kids
smile at you and then wave at you
you go past or or when you say goodbye
it's brilliant i promised every one of
the kids that i gave the laptop to that
after this period is over then i'm going
to go and take him out for a drive with
tara
so i'm going to be busy
if you can if you can fit a sky news
presenter in the back i'm sure i can
think of at least one who might want to
have a go as well
i suppose i suppose the the big question
on all of this this is clearly a
fantastic idea
you've obviously got decades of as you
described it geek experience in the i.t
world but there are other geeks out
there as well
aren't there who may want to do exactly
the same can we
see this scheme perhaps being being done
more broadly by others with a similar
skill set to you
i would love to in fact there are three
things that i'm now turning my mind to
one is of course get even more laptops
because this is like a never-ending uh
demand for it
uh number two is to find some some local
points so i can deliver so tara and i
don't have to drive around for half a
day to pick them up
and the third is to find similar
individuals
you know semi-retired whatever around
the country because to do
this is really easy um it takes about
half an hour per laptop
um and it really is a doddle in fact i
found already two people and i'm doing a
zoom training course with them
they're both in the local area but i
really think this can go national
and and the the the generosity of people
in
in in donating laptops blew me away neil
i thought i was going to do five then
that's it i'm at 50 plus
it's it's amazing it's fantastic
um look do you know what prim i have to
say doing the job that i do is not
always a battle of laughs we have to
give the nation some pretty bad news
every day
the thing that keeps me getting up in
the morning people like you
and your stories so seriously fantastic
work
at premgiani many many thanks for
joining us in the program
and many many thanks for what you're
doing thank you can i just
say that if people want to give me
laptops then if they go to
weddingtuktuk.com they can
subscribe there i will stick that
information out on my social channel
weddingtux.com for your laptops
we'll see you soon